my name is Frank Kelly and I'm here with
Giles so we're talking about us you
could say a small project we've been
working on that puts data science to a
good cause really it's and it's a cause
that I've been personally affected by
and we think it's very much worthwhile
so will explain a bit about what we've
been doing we're going to talk a bit
about the way we've looked at this
problem and identified features and then
built some models and then try to draw
conclude conclusions and we'll share
some of our findings and results okay
sure okay
so what is our goal with this so we
ideally we want to develop a way using
data to diagnose Alzheimer's disease as
early as possible so a little bit of
background about Alzheimer's disease
it affects millions of people around the
world it's the most common form of
dementia say 70% of dementia is
Alzheimer's usually there's a quite a
shocking statistic in the UK there are
about 800,000 people in the formally
diagnosed sure is that better
so in the UK there's about 800,000
people who've been formally diagnosed
but there's perhaps a million more who
who have symptoms of Alzheimer's and yet
they don't really know and they may get
all the way through to sort of chronic
stage of Alzheimer's without being
formally diagnosed or treated which is
quite a shocking situation I'm sure
you'd agree so
and it's it's gonna get worse
unfortunately if you look at population
demographics to the chart on the left is
is showing that as as populations get
older around the world so the ratio of
people who can care for people have
things like dementia is is is is
diminishing so that that's the ratio
dependence on the left on the right
country like Japan you're gonna see yeah
the number of people suffering from
something like Alzheimer's or dementia
is going to triple so this is a huge
problem so who are we I've introduced
myself and Charles earlier but there's a
couple of other people working with us
on this you could say it's a part-time
site project so we get together once
every three weeks or if at best every
two weeks over unlike one of us is in
Canada the girl there Maya and there's a
chap on the right he's in Spain we're
both in the London area but we managed
to get online and do a little bit of
hacking and playing the data and so it's
really this is just a project on the
side we're not no major promises about
what we can achieve with it but it's
we're here to share what we've done so
in terms of our yeah are thinking so
outside of disease today is usually
diagnosed by a trip to a GP so starting
with they look at you your medical
history they'll perform some tests and
you know it's it's a one-time event so
you you come in you have a test and
you've you've suddenly you've got
outside as your diagnosed and eventually
you know you could go up to doing brain
imaging and eventually dissecting the
brain to really confirm that Alzheimer's
has taken place but we know that as
homes it's really a it's a gradual
decline occurring in the brain and so
the diagnosis period is you know usually
between say 13 years
and six years before the the person dies
but if you look you can you know it
often happens up to 20 years before that
the conditions start to happen so there
are many benefits from you know earlier
diagnosis not only in terms of the
individual and their and their families
in terms of their planning and
responsibilities and you know they're
reducing their anxieties also there's
there are interesting developments in
terms of drugs that may be able to slow
down the effect of the disease and if if
more people can start to be on drug
trials earlier then then I think that
bodes well and the you know potential
cure will be closer to looking at cures
and really ways to it tackle it so
looking a bit of a ha
so we how do we start out so we we
thought we'd look into the domain area
get a bit of knowledge before diving in
to you know creating features and doing
some analysis so Alzheimer's really
manifests itself by well delete the
leading hypothesis is that you have
these protein plaques that accumulates
in the brain and they really disrupt
communication between cells I'm not sure
whether they actually kill cells I'm not
a domain expert I understand there's
been some experiments when they managed
to stimulate neurons in the brain and
they and memories were able to be
brought back afterwards on mice so I'm
not sure how and and I don't think even
the leading experts entirely understand
the cause or the impact of the disease
but what we do know is that it starts in
one part of the brain which is the
hippocampus so this is where where our
recent memories performed
and then and so that so the earliest
symptoms you see is short-term memory
loss difficult to people having trouble
recollecting certain recent events and
then the disease process progresses
through the front part of the brain and
moves on to areas such as language
processing and and eventually goes
through logical thought emotions the
senses and on sort of older memory the
rate of decline we know it varies for
men and women that's been recently
discovered but eventually of course this
will lead to full shutdown at the brain
because the even the sort of
life-support systems will be eventually
shut down so how do we turn this into a
to a data science problem well we think
we took all the symptoms that we could
read about in various papers and we try
to match them roughly with this timeline
it's all very approximate but we we try
to think about where we might get some
data and we start with the idea of
written correspondence because it's
already digital easy to access so in
terms of what we could pick out from
people's written correspondence we
selected these features so starting it's
also trying to find features that were
tally with early early at the earliest
symptoms and that part of the condition
so these three so so language problems
so memory issues and change in sentiment
and mood we're areas we decided to focus
on
so previously I don't know if some of
you come to the PI data meetups I did a
lightning talk and we started up by
picking up a single Alzheimer's
sufferers emails and doing some analysis
so we converted emails to two vectors
and eventually counts and numbers and
and extracted a few features so here
we've got readability over time over so
VA the age for the patient was between
78 and 82 and yes she's actually the
grandmother of one of the people
collaborating on this team the thing is
well so we saw some there's some example
emails there that we were looking at for
example we saw some sort of trends over
these four years it's hard to really be
conclusive and looking at email in
general we made a lot of inquiries and
we spoke to some organizations about
getting access to volunteers emails the
problem is people there's a lot of
security concerns and and people
actually often delete their emails so we
decided to to change tack slightly so
I'm gonna head over to Giles now let's
go talk about approach
okay so yeah one of the big issues with
the email is how do you get hold of it
and that's pretty tricky so we looked
around for other places we could get the
data from and the Alzheimer Society UK
forums was the most accessible place
where we could get a lot of written data
produced by both sufferers and non
sufferers of dementia so we've used the
I have a partner with dementia sub-forum
as our counterpoint to the I have
dementia sub forum which we hope will
allow us to control some extent for age
and education of the subjects so there
was an initial LOL xml scraper that we
used and we rewrote this later into a
beautiful suit which basically made it
easier for us to get more content from
these posts so we scraped two sub forums
3,600 threads approximately and about
30% of those were started by sufferers
of dementia or at least that was the sub
forum they were in and 78,000 posts
unfortunately the majority of those as
you might expect from Norman sufferers
or rather in the non sufferers partners
forum so we grabbed the post content the
metadata the user meta data and output
that lot to a couple of rather sizable
dataframes well in terms of big data but
that gave us something to to play with
so beautiful soups made things very easy
for us we did a little bit of text
cleaning but not very much required just
the bare minimum to put things into an l
ck basically we removed the quotes from
the posts you can imagine that good to
contaminate any signal quite
significantly and use rare games just a
tidy stuff up a little bit nothing
complicated so you've got the user
metadata frame or small chunk of it up
on the right there you can see that we
have issues with some posters post a lot
and other posters only post once or
twice so we do have issues with various
biases in the beta and the actual post
content with the record of the the
thread it's in the post count is very
important so the first post in the
thread is the one that we prefer to use
to classify a user if they've started a
thread in the in either sub forum we can
probably assume that there we can
classify them appropriate to that sub
forum whereas if they're replying then
they could be a dementia softener for
replying in the partners forum or
vice-versa
so that's pretty difficult so labeling
the users is a bit of an issue
I can actually crank this is yours so
yeah we we determined a source of data
and what was our strategy well we just
we wanted to engineer some features that
would match the symptoms I've described
and we wanted to somehow aggregate these
posts in a way that could be analyzed
and features expected for them in a
meaningful fashion we also wanted to
select a few models and do some
classification so something on user
classification here I think just you
wanted to talk about that so how do we
label users so unfortunately individual
users rarely sorry fortunately
individual users rarely start threats in
both sub forums if they do we discard
them so there's only 12 in that case so
we don't lose too many users but replies
in both sub forums are common and so if
we look at some examples here we can see
that the first user in this frame 18 Roy
well he's only posted in the partner
forum so that's fine we can classify him
as a partner he started the thread and
he's replied a couple of times as well
Mindi that's fairly clear she started
thirteen threads and although she's
replied to a few posts in the the
partners of sorry the dementia sufferers
forum she's replied to a lot more in the
partners for him so we can confidently
think that she's a partner to J's so
this one I if you were not being too
cautious you would classify as a partner
of a dementia suffer because of the
ratio of posts here
but in fact we've taken a cautious
approach and it's a compromise between
the quality and the quantity of data we
have but we've thrown out anything
that's ambiguous like that
53 sharon has started and replied to
threads only in the dementia forum so
we're pretty confident that's a dementia
sufferer and sixties child is a really
difficult one because they haven't
started any threads and they've posted
almost equally in each sub forum so
unfortunately that's data that we we
wouldn't use so in summary we discard
users who start threads in both forums
we're also currently leaving out users
who have replied to threads in both sub
forums we could use those that
predominantly reply in one sub forum but
for reliability it doesn't give us much
extra to work with so we just been that
data so that gives us unfortunately to
quite biased groups of users we have a
lot more partners of sufferers but it's
something to work with so over to Frank
so
once we established more or less who who
a user is whether they're a sufferer or
partner we weren't entirely sure we
didn't manually go through every single
posters as Josh said but we got a you
know we were fairly confident about our
initial data we decided to design some
features so to start with we just put
some very basic features to do with
counting counting words counts and
censuses and unique words word count and
encouragingly if we plot a histogram of
posts we see differences straightaway so
we see that sufferers are generally they
seem to be writing longer sentences
which sounds strange but it might be we
figure because they're not maybe using
punctuation as often so you see a sort
of a wider spread more variation this
things like yeah sentiment there's a
package called text blog you can just
pull out and you can it's a fairly basic
procedure you're able to analyze the
sentiment of every word in the sentence
so we saw that also quite strangely they
the dementia sufferers tended to have
more positive sentiments than their
partners it could be because of the sort
of state of mind it could be because
their partners are more worried than
they are there could many other reasons
it could be just noise in the data at
this stage so but that's sort of initial
patterns we're seeing so a couple of
other features things like go ahead
words this sort of thing you can you
wrote a function to sort of count these
in the post because that's the feature
of out sign of sufferers according to
several
so we looked into you know without Simas
you tend to get a loss of lexical
functions or vocabulary
tends to diminish and people tend to use
words out of place so they might use
words they've come up with themselves or
words that really aren't relevant to
what they're talking about and then
there's general comprehension of what
they're saying so something like a
readability metric should help us with
that
so readability metrics we we found a
quite a good package called readability
l xml it runs all of these metrics for
you straight away on on the text and
here's a couple of them plotted so what
what we see again is is reflected once
more so there's greater variation within
the dementia set in all of these metrics
but the Dement there's a tendency for
strangely the compromised comprehension
to be so it's slightly harder to read so
so the readability metrics are aimed
matching sort of an age group as in
people aged 13 to 16 would have no
trouble reading this or no it's actually
only people aged 10 to 13 could read
this so we found that the dementia text
was actually harder to read so without
trying to read too much into the the
reasons behind this we explore the data
a bit further supporting plotting on two
dimensions these are these are
individual posts plotted so these are
different metrics I don't know if you
can read the axes but there's things
like Dale Chow readability which is made
up of the number of difficult words
and and the number of words per sentence
so you see the interestingly and
encouraging me you see the dementia sort
of increase variation it's almost like
the dementia sufferers poster sort of
breaking away from the norm as it were
that's what we could see so after
exploring the data sort of post by post
yeah oh yes sorry there's a memory or
into the future as well so we just did a
very simple comparing we just use pandas
group by and ordered ordered all the
posts and for each user we we
semantically compared the post for the
previous post using cosine similarity
and I tried another one part of n LT k
package the edit distance which I think
is related to a number of characters
you'd have to rearrange in the sentence
to make it match the previous one so
this has to do with people repeating
themselves basically and there see if we
could quantify that
so thinking about in terms of now we
have the feature set what are we doing
here we are we trying to make a
prediction of whether someone has
answers and we're trying to just explain
the causes well in fact we we need to
undertake both approaches so we start by
training a classifier to find out which
variables influence routes hymens that
we can see and this will be explanatory
and then eventually we need to work on a
predictive power in terms of determining
you know when when it when is out so I
was starting to happen in somebody puts
an unknown so in terms of initial
explanatory modeling phase we want we
started by aggregating the users data so
we took median values and so for each
user we took all their posts and worked
out the median of the relevant metric
and we did some sampling we do that we
had a holdout set as well and this is
the model result so if we chose the
group our features into difference that
so the first group were the sort of
miscellaneous features so we put
sentiment and the first metrics I showed
you so we we just put if we we ran a few
different classifiers and the results
were not they're great as you can see
this ROC curve it's not brilliant the
sentiment came up as top this used to be
of differentiating factor then we looked
at the memory features slightly better
so 63 percent accuracy but the precision
isn't amazing and it seems to be this
cosine similarity metric we tried the
mean and the standard deviation to count
for the fact that the we'd aggregated
the data and just the mean on it's a
wasn't telling us much that came up on
top the readability features once more
aggregated not so great again so 59%
but this Dale Chelle this readability
the one I plotted earlier this is a
feature importance we were just using
the random forest function to be able to
explain importance of features it came
out as a really important metric and
then we did some part of speech so
breaking settles down determining what
what type of each word so we looked at
adjectives nouns pronouns and verbs and
we're able to calculate a rate as in how
many verbs divided by how many words in
a sentence
so two minutes left so yeah we found
that this support vector machine radial
basis function seemed to seem to do the
best but again not brilliant and when we
combined all of the features into one
model you yeah so we're getting about 63
percent accuracy and there's a sort of a
mixture between readability sentiment
memory features coming up so we but we
had a slight change in attack we decided
to classify posts and not users but the
problem is we found that so many more
there are many more partners than
dementia sufferers on the forum and in
general partners were writing three
times as many posts that as dementia
sufferers so we had to sort of do this
double round of sampling so we'd even up
our data set but that paid off and we
got a sort of accuracy of up to 68
percent with a random forest classifier
and this is the only slide won't brave
enough to put a confusion matrix on
because the results were getting looking
a bit more encouraging and the memory
feature came up top so just to just to
wrap up memory based features seem to do
the the best and the best performing
individual feature was verb rate in the
case of aggregated data but if on
individual posts it was cosine
surrounded so previous post and this
this falls into line with what we
determine in terms of
so we want to look into many future
avenues including grouping of users
improving every phase of this pipeline
so getting better data to start with and
classifying users to start with you know
in a clever fashion we want to collect
more features we want to do different
kinds of classification and move on to
the predictive element which will
probably involve some kind of time
series analysis so we thought about we
noticed this dimension software here if
you
they've been posting a long time on this
forum and we see like an increase in the
in the variance so maybe that's going to
be a way to detect for certain features
it might be a change in the mean like a
brand some things there's something want
to look at so I think I have to finish
that we're all all done so thank you for
listening to us we have given you an
introduction to art Simon's some of our
initial findings from this very small
side project it's a tough problem what
we think is worthwhile if if any of you
would like to help and do you think you
can do this a lot better than us then
please get in touch
it can come and chat to me afterwards or
drop us an email online through the
links thank you very much
that's right yes
no it's it was purely for you through
ease of use in in our case so it
probably doesn't relate to the different
classifiers yeah certain classifiers we
found that aren't very good for a sort
of explanatory problem they're more a
sort of black box give them some inputs
and get some outputs so we were just
using the random forest as a way of just
comparing at the groups of features as
we went through
that's true so somewhere around 80%
would be great the key is to just
eventually this might turn into an
application so we've just alert people
it might say to you after reading your
emails for a few months they might say
well can you can you make an appointment
with your GP I'll just go and have a
chat and so it's I suppose it's better
to err on the side of say 80 90 % so
this is really more of a curiosity than
something deployable and it's a very
long way off that obviously in anything
medical any false positives or any false
negatives are a big issue and tend to
scare people so you know there's massive
doses of caution would need to be
applied to anything that comes out of
the other end of this
I think that so that was I think feature
importance of the different features
which is not the same as a predominant
those features are the nouns and the
verbs well it was did did you see it
earlier on did you but it's it's just
it's just interning the its we don't
know whether it's more or less actually
it's just determining it was important
definitely yes
so are you working this are you working
in this domain
like we haven't gone into that level of
detail the one thing that comes to mind
is that they did tend to use more
difficult words and fewer common words I
don't have that Tally's though what
you're saying that's right in the
English language yeah thank you
takes the text blog yeah
the experience was that it was very easy
to use and to get set up
you don't yeah it's it's got its own
pre-pre sentiment analyzed vocabulary so
you can just throw it a sentence and it
will it'll return the not not not not as
yet but that's it's good it's on the
list yes yeah do you have any
recommendations okay
right yeah so we have thought about that
and we want to add more forums so that
are unrelated the thing about the
partners is that they're of a similar
age group usually to the dementia
sufferers so there are presumably
factors that occur just a standard
decline for during old age so that was a
way of normalizing that but yeah you're
right they're going to be worried and
that's why they're posting three times
as much maybe it's and yeah it's
definitely a factor so yeah so at
different forums there was one like I'm
a carer of an outsider patient and yeah
we may just pick some completely
unrelated ones just to see how they'd
have the features Tali
for now we've just used the simple the
the output from the random forest in in
scikit-learn
with the only thing we did was to to
group the features initially and try
them out in separate groups so that
would give us an indication at the sort
of main areas but you're right we should
do some more careful feature selection
and then observe the impact on the model
right
yes yeah there's various approaches you
know can have a check after as if you
like him I just wanted to add to that
we've done very little in the way of
optimization we haven't done proper high
parameter searches you know very much
from the sort out the methodology and
then we've just thrown the data at
classifiers and seen what's come out
with practically no tuning so it's not
very sophisticated at this point so we
probably have to wrap things up